le plan vigipirate a été renforcée dans
le centre commercial de vélizy 2 pour
cette fin d'année notamment à travers la
collaboration entre les forces de
l'ordre les agents de sécurité privés et
les acteurs de la structure c'est tout
un accompagnement sur les bons réflexes
les bons gestes en accompagnement avec
les forces de police qui sont aussi en
soutien on a des référents sûreté au
niveau des forces de police qui viennent
sensibiliser l'ensemble des commerçants
le ministre de l'intérieur bruno le roux
est venu constater la mise en oeuvre du
plan de sécurité renforcées pour la
période des fêtes ce samedi 17 décembre
en finale après avoir visité le pc de
sécurité le résident de la place beauvau
a tenu aussi à échanger avec les
commerçants leur ajoutant une nouvelle
mission la protection du client
là par exemple dans cette période vous
avez du surplus de personnel des frites
et appelle à renforcer l'effectif donc
ça fait partie quand il arrive des
éléments de formation colorado leur dire
comment il doit se comporter s'il ya une
alerte de cetains un actif de la période
d'offre fait entrer cette dimension de
la sécurité au quotidien dans les plans
de formation de tous ceux qui
accueillent du public et elle me le
confirmait son rôle est d'accueillir son
rôle est d'orienter de conseiller mais
son rôle est aussi de protéger les
clients quand ils sont à l'intérieur de
son magasin
moi je ne
aucun de nos concitoyens ne renonce à
aller faire ses courses ne renonce à sa
muse et ne renonce à venir dans les
centres commerciaux
le partenariat entre pouvoirs publics et
acteurs privés permet d'assurer le
renforcement du dispositif de sécurité
pour les fêtes de fin d'année